my name is janice alyong
i am a senior staff scientist at life
technologies where i've been since 2006
i work in the medical sciences r d group
and i will discuss companion diagnostics
opportunities with you today using our
technology and strategy
i would like to mention at this time
when questions come to mind during my
talk
you should submit those questions by
typing them into the q a window on your
screen
the title of today's talk is companion
diagnostics co-development
are you ready
we will look at some of the factors
involved in co-development of a
companion diagnostics test
many decisions are made long before
development of a diagnostic test begins
a biomarker test using off-the-shelf
assays in the research lab may have
potential as a diagnostic
and then what
what are the key considerations in
choosing a companion diagnostics partner
first
is technology
second
experience in diagnostic development
such as design control
regulatory expertise
manufacturing
third is global commercialization
strategy
and fourth
is competent management of the companion
diagnostics partnership
go to slide two
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
our company
and i will talk
for about half of the talk on technology
and then the second part will consist of
companion diagnostics
topics
our company is headquartered in carlsbad
california
we were incorporated as life
technologies
formed by the merger of applied
biosystems and in vitrogen in 2008.
currently we are traded on the nasdaq
stock exchange under the life ticker
symbol
and as you have probably heard
we plan to merge with thermo fisher
subject to regulatory approval next year
in 2014
this slide shows our businesses and the
diversity of life sciences served by our
company
first
we are well known for providing tools
and instruments for solutions in basic
and translational research
second with these capabilities we are
committed to developing diagnostic
applications in molecular medicine
and this will be the bulk of what i am
discussing today
third are forensic
testing kits are used to solve crimes
and also in human identification for
example
this technology was used to reunite
families
who are separators after crimes of human
trafficking
the fourth business is our food and
water safety
this was used for monitoring at the last
summer olympics by the uk's health
protection agency to insured food to
ensure food safety
and then lastly synthetic biology
what is that
it combines molecular biology
and systems biology
with applications in biofuels
industrial enzymes
bio cloning and gene synthesis
our mission statement is to make life
even better
what technology's brands are shown here
it's a little bit like introducing the
starting lineup of a baseball team
so i'll start with the laid off brand
when we merged with in vitrogen the
applied biosystems brand was still
retained
and that brand name remains on our
products today
so applied biosystems instruments that
were manufactured under the applied
biosystems incorporated
company for example still will bear the
av brand
but they are supported under life
technologies
second up
is the ion torrent brand
rather small to see
iron torrent uses semiconductor
technology to deliver the fastest
benchtop next-gen sequencing
third up
next to iron torrent is the novx brand
which has reagents and consumables for
protein separation
fourth up is the taqman
real-time pcr brand which uses pro-based
chemistry for quantitative gene
expression
genotyping
copy number
and mutation detection
fifth up is ambien ambien provides high
quality innovative rna products
for purification
and transcriptome analysis
next step is molecular probes which has
novel fluorescent reagents for flow
cytometry and other cell biology
applications
seventh is gibco
gibco supplies cell culture media for
the highest quality consistency and
performance for reproducibility in cell
biology and cell-based technologies
and then finally branding eighth is in
vitrogen
who was a pioneer in molecular biology
providing cloning and expression kits
and who is still well known in providing
tools for genomics and proteomics
research
you can conclude from this that life tax
business is product development
our product commercialization process is
used for reaching checkpoints in
development manufacturing and product
launch
this capability as you will see extends
to companion diagnostics development
our next corporate slide shows quick
facts about life
we are a global company with presence in
over 180 companies
countries
we have over
1500 scientists
over 10 000 employees with six hundred
thousand plus citations in the
literature using our products
and over four thousand patents issued
and pending
our customer base is over seventy five
thousand
with 3.7 billion
dollars in sales for 2012.
this slide shows the markets served by
our business
currently
life check is organized in three
divisions
research science applied sciences and
medical sciences
as i've described the research science
division has tools for molecular and
cellular biology and also
is an umbrella for the genetic analysis
platforms
such as
quantitative pcr and tacman
ce sequencing
and next-gen sequencing
applied sciences are represented by
synthetic biology
food safety
animal health
human identification bioproduction and
agriculture biotechnology
medical sciences
is the umbrella for molecular
diagnostics as well as genomic medicine
and regenerative medicine
such as stem cell biology
three recent acquisitions in medical
sciences show life tax commitment to
molecular diagnostics and medical
devices
all in 2012 i'm going to describe three
acquisitions
last october life tech acquired
compendia
bioscience
a preeminent cancer bioinformatics
company
founded by aral chennai and dan rhodes
the services of this company are widely
used by pharma
to identify novel gene targets for drug
discovery and development compendia has
sequence data from over 62 thousand
cancer patients
its deep oncology expertise and high
value
proprietary assets
enhanced
technology's diagnostic development
capabilities across multiple platforms
including next-gen sequencing
qpcr and proteome analysis
the second acquisition i will describe
is pinpoint genomics
and their clia approved lung cancer test
to read more about this
go to a lancet publication which
appeared last year entitled a practical
molecular assay to predict survival in
refected non-squamous non-small cell
lung cancer
development and international validation
studies
the third acquisition was
navigence which expanded life
technology's capabilities and
diagnostics
this next slide
has examples of our technology
as applied to diagnostic tools used to
provide solutions
our diversified product lines are
instruments and reagents
which we provide as you can see on the
left as oem
that stands for original equipment
manufacturer
where we supply these tools for research
use only
in addition
many of these are
sold
to
other companies
who retail
those products under a third-party
purchasing company's brand name
so for example dynal beads
those are used in more than 25 thousand
ivd instruments
so these beads are optimized for
immunoassay ivd
molecular diagnostics and nucleic acid
ivd
they have features well suited for
diagnostic athletes such as fast
kinetics and high capacity
high signal to noise ratio
quality and lot to lot reproducibility
molecular probes is a well-known brand
for cell labeling
and detection used for fluorescence
imaging
flow cytometry and cell viability assays
used in clinical labs
finally tropics
substrates are used as chemi
luminescence substrates for detection of
alkaline phosphatase in elisa
and reporter gene assays for general lab
use as well as ivd
in the middle under lab tools
are examples of life technologies
instruments
the
ab-3130
is used for fragment analysis and
sequencing
in clinical labs for diagnostic virology
testing
and microsatellite-based genotyping
and it can also be used as an open
platform allowing for custom test
development
right in the middle there is the verity
dx
thermal cycler which is the first
applied biosystems endpoint thermal
cycler for in vitro diagnostic use
on the verity
is classified as a usfda class 1 medical
device
it conforms to ivdd
requirements and is ceivd labeled in
europe
the instrument is manufactured to iso 13
485 and gmp requirements
the instrument is available in three
formats for thermal cycling
96 well both standard and fast and
standard 384 well all three systems
feature an exceptionally easy to operate
color touch screen to simplify
instrument setup and use
this instrument is available in the us
europe and other selected countries
the last
tool that's shown in the middle is
acrometrics
echometrics is a company which life tech
acquired in the year 2010
and it offers a range of high quality
molecular products designed to meet
customer needs
the product range includes controls and
standards to assist in the
implementation
and monitoring of diagnostic assays for
clinical labs blood centers and
manufacturers
on the right are our regulated solutions
for ivd products
first
the 7500 fast dx instrument
it has a regulatory 510k clearance
as a clinical multiplex instrument
second
life technologies launched the ce ivd
marked quant studio dx for quantitative
pcr last november for clinical
diagnostics labs in europe
in addition in march
the fda cleared
the quadell
c diff assay for our quant studio dx
and the 7500 dx
the instrument can perform diagnostic
functions
including pathogen detection gene
expression analysis
snip genotyping copy number analysis
mutation detection
micro rna and other non-coding rna
analysis
and high resolution melt analysis
third and finally in february of this
year
the fda cleared lifetext 3500 dx genetic
analyzers
and the c-core hla typing kits
the first 510 cleared sequence based
system for hla typing in the us
also the 3500 dx is now the only 510
cleared sanger sequencer commercially
available for the diagnostics market
lifetech's worldwide install base of
real-time pcr instruments
is greater than 28 000 units
of the 28 000 instruments in labs around
the world
approximately
7 500 are placed in labs in clinical
testing labs
so if you look at the horizontal running
through the middle of the slide this
shows the continuum of discovery to
characterization to screening
live tech instruments and tools
cover this spectrum
the vertical arrow from top to bottom on
the right shows the continuum of ruo to
ivd
thus the instruments above the
horizontal line
or arrow
are for ruo
but in addition we offer diagnostic
platform solutions
customized for the number and type of
analytes with simple and reliable
workflows amenable to ivd so those are
the instruments that are below the
horizontal arrow
i hope you will see that this
demonstrates life tech's commitment
to both research and diagnostic testing
if you look at the left
is there is a photo of our next gen
sequencing instrument the ion torrent
proton which is for genome scale
discovery
largely for research
next to it is the ion torrent pgm or
personal genome machine
and this is as you can read for targeted
sequencing resequencing and expression
analysis
note that the ion torrent is not
currently cleared by the fda
but it will be ready for diagnostic
purposes in the near future
if you would like to know more about
iron torrent technology and applications
in biomarkers and diagnostics
you can listen to the presentation given
yesterday
by brian kelly from life tech
entitled unlocking the potential of
precision medicine with ion torrent
semiconductor sequencing
next capillary electrophoresis in the
middle of the slide
is useful for discovery and also it
provides unequivocal evidence of somatic
mutations
specifically
when the mutations or alleles
in a region of interest are not known
this technology can be advantageous
however it does not detect deletions
of an entire exon
or amplifications
and in the case of mutation detection
ce sequencing requires the mutation to
be present
in at least 20 of the dna
samples yeah
and at least 20 of the dna templates in
a sample
it is useful for characterization and
screening of polymorphic
loci and as i mentioned in february
life tech received an fda clearance for
the 3500 dx genetic analyzers
and for its c-core hla typing kits
life tech received the 510k clearance
for the 3500 dx
and the quant studio dx
pcr system this year
these two systems
have been designed specifically
for use in the clinical testing
laboratory
and will serve as lifetext flagship
diagnostic instruments for qpcr and
saying or sequencing respectively
all the way to the right
is represented our taqman assay
platforms
which include over 1.2
million gene expression assays for human
and model organisms
1.6 million
human copy number assays
4.5 million human snip assays and 2700
human
dme genotyping assays
also included are 12 000 non-coding rna
and finally
over 700 mutation detection assays
our platform of mutation specific assays
are called tacmancast pcr so cast pcr
stands for competitive
allele specific tacman pcr
this is a cost effective solution
and in most cases it is more sensitive
than sequencing when tumor cells
represent a minor fraction of the cells
in the clinical sample
so for example the cast pcr assays can
detect 10 copies of mutant
in the background of 10 000
wild-type copies which is a sensitivity
of 0.1 percent
the set of approximately 800 tacman cast
pcr assay
are
designed for 46 genes with hot spot
mutations
these are now commercially available and
they have been actually since them last
year
so our off-the-shelf assays
have been tested and optimized
if we are missing a marker of interest
we are able to run the sequence through
our bioinformatics pipeline to generate
a custom assay
as such like text cells gmp oligos and
enzymes for our diagnostic customers
that require analyte specific reagents
i mentioned
in 2010 that we acquired acrometrics and
so that's the
last
icon on the lower right
the acrometric cell standards and
controls
now the scientists at acrometrics
realize
the process of implementing molecular
assays in labs can be tedious
new labs lacking knowledge
and existing labs wanting to simplify
and streamline their implementation
process
my colleague from acrometrics
jerry boonyara tanacorn kit
we'll speak tomorrow at 9 00 am and he
will describe the easy qc online
a web-based tool for quality control
management
and this will help labs overcome these
challenges
jerry will walk through the validation
process providing guidelines and other
quality control solutions to assist
clinical labs in meeting their
verification validation and semi-annual
calibration verification requirements
to summarize this
slide
the fda clearance of the quant studio
and the 3500 dx
represents execution against the
company's strategy to become a leader in
the diagnostics market
by offering both novel
clinical assays and best-in-class
molecular testing products lifechef is
aggressively investing in its product
portfolio to expand its molecular
diagnostic capabilities
here are two examples
life tech has agreements to co-develop
companion diagnostics with
glaxosmithkline and bristol-myers squibb
the bms master services agreement is for
oncology and a broad range of
therapeutic
areas
the agreement will facilitate
co-development
that is initiated earlier rather than
later in the drug development cycle
from phase one and two
to cover feasibility studies
to clinical validation
and further development
commercialization of companion
diagnostics tests
the gfk agreement was signed in 2011
for developing a qpcr-based
molecular diagnostic assay for gfks mage
a3 cancer immunotherapy
candidate
designed to identify patients most
likely to benefit from the therapy
so the lifetech platform is being
evaluated as a companion diagnostic
for gsk's cancer vaccine
a multi-gene panel of taqman gene
expression assays on a tacman array
cards
have been selected to support clinical
development
of candidate immunotherapy
for two clinical trials
the platform will measure gene
expression of mrna from ffte samples to
aid in the assessment of patients who
are more likely to benefit from adjuvant
treatment
in resected non-small cell lung cancer
and also in patients with node positive
melanoma
life check is developing the assay
supporting regulatory approval
and commercialization of the assay
the differences in timelines
for drug development and diagnostic
development
is outlined here
it takes a minimum of twice as long to
launch a drug
and probably cost a thousand times more
development of a drug
and a diagnostic to go with it depends
on
collaboration
of the pharma with its diagnostic
developer
thus it's very important to choose the
right partner early on
why is this
the decision point for incorporating a
companion diagnostics may begin in phase
two
and the fda as you know will ultimately
approve the cdx and the drug together
based on their combined safety and
efficacy
if it becomes necessary to bridge
the assay
that is if you need to change anything
about the assay design
if you need to change reagents
control the instrument
then you will need to show that the
previous data is the same as what is in
the fda submission
bridging studies increase risk
and they also make judgments of safety
and efficacy more difficult
if there is variability in the bridging
between devices this will add
uncertainty to the end points
and so in essence this may require more
samples to be tested
or more power
where more replicates are needed
per reaction to make up for the
variability
in an ideal world it would begin
with collaboration between pharma and
the diagnostic developer
it should begin before phase one
clinical trials
when discovery phase begins with
biomarker identification followed by
target identification and validation for
selection of the assay
and by picking components which are
suited for diagnostic assay development
but this may not be the case
life technologies believes in a flexible
approach
not a one-size-fits-all
meaning that the basis for selecting a
biomarker
or target is derived in many ways and
from diverse sources
we propose
we support and recommend what suits the
pharma customer
whether
it is a clinical trial assay
a lab developed test
or what we call an ldt pma developed in
a clia lab
or a full ivd test
life tech has strategic partnerships
with cros
which provide a diversity of support
depending on the requirements for the
project in question
a lot of times pharma researchers come
to us with feasibility data the data may
be from in-house labs or it can be from
a cro
they show that they've identified a
biomarker often with our technology
which is a potential companion
diagnostic for the drug
so pharma has this hypothesis
that the genetic alteration whether it
is a mutation a gene amplification
a change in relative expression that
that is predictive of a therapeutic
response
and thus
selection of patients for treatment
our job is to design an accurate and
cost-effective method to identify this
genetic alteration
these critical decisions early on can
determine the likelihood of success with
respect to platform selection
essay development
and design and regulatory and quality
strategy
the selection of a partner with the end
goal in mind reduces risk
as a drug developer we strive to design
a prototype
and so going through feasibility to
clinical validation
this prototype
needs to align with the drug developers
timeline
once it's decided that a companion
diagnostic test is needed by a pharma
company
our goal at life tech is to understand
as much as possible so that we can
propose a workable flexible solution to
our customers
these questions help us make
recommendations on next steps
what essay are you using
was it built from scratch
are multiple biomarkers being detected
how was the test designed is it one of
our off-the-shelf assays
for assay design
are there preliminary screening
questions employed in other words is it
a standalone test or is it one of a
series of tests
if the assay design requires
optimization
or if the assay design is needed for a
novel mutation that we do not yet have
as a research use only assay it is
relatively easy to generate
new taqman assays using our
bioinformatics pipeline
this actually plays to our strength
in that we have developed at life tech
many of the technologies which are used
on our instruments
other questions
does the scientific literature support
this biomarker
this has to do with its clinical utility
is it potentially useful for the patient
what are the clinical findings
is the clinical trial set up to study
the markers
we need to know
answers to questions about the disease
or type of disorder
what is the specific clinical disease
in in oncology
has the test been applied to a specific
subtype
of cancer or
just to solid tumors in general
what are the clinical findings defining
this disorder
what is the prevalence of the marker
or mutation in the specific type of
cancers
are there epidemiologic factors such as
smokers versus non-smokers
ethnic association age etc all these are
important for us as a diagnostic
developer
when considering how easy or difficult
it will be to acquire clinical samples
needed for development and clinical
testing
is the test new to the fda
if a similar test platform has been
previously cleared this reduces risk to
the submission
and then
finally ip issues will we need to
license the ip in order to make a
diagnostic test
more questions what does your current
assay look like
so typically when we are exploring
a new assay
we look at five
components
so they're listed here in detail so
basically it's sample
the assay
the instrument
the software
and the controls
so for sample processing one has to
consider sample collection sample
storage sample prep
sample extraction
we have a number of commercial kits
which are available for nucleic acids
ambien has rua products that are an
ideal starting point for sample prep
for assay i've already discussed this in
some details
with pacman and sanger sequencing
in the future we hope to have our next
gen sequencing as an
assay platform
for companion diagnostics
third i've mentioned acrometrics who
build
controls for both infectious disease and
oncology with gmp
i've talked a lot about our our
instrument platform
those that have five 10k clearances for
qpcr as well
as for ce sequencing and then we also
build software that goes with our
instruments for both primary data
reporting and interpretive software for
analysis of the primary data
of course the million dollar question is
can your assay be successful
so what is needed
to make
an assay
it's not just the scientific aspect
there are commercial aspects
so there are challenges to profitability
such as low test volume
low reimbursement
or maybe even lack of reimbursement
and then one has to ask whether there
are other assays on the market which are
equivalent to the assay being proposed
with respect to the markers what is the
ease of use in the lab
and what's the practicality for example
if sample is limiting
for example
with non-small cell lung cancer
are there workarounds
can pre-amplification be used
what's the footprint in the lab
are there sufficient diagnostic
capabilities and infrastructure for
launch
specifically is the install base for the
instrument adequate
then there are issues around sales
who can sell it
do is there a global sales force in
place
so possible obstacles to success are
what if you have a commercial presence
in the countries where the test is to be
used
but
the commercial
force is not deployed yet for the target
market
there has to be some training done
in order to target the market
and then what about opportunities for
co-promotion of the drug with the
diagnostic test
also
together the pharma with the diagnostic
partner needs to plan
for regions with thought leaders those
who can
enable the test to be deployed
market development activities
need to be planned
educational materials need to be
developed and validated
and then i also mentioned countries
so country specific distribution
channels
as well as a chronological launch plan
there is a need for specific
steady and regulatory requirements for
certain regions in the world
i mentioned training for sales reps for
call points so the goal here is to
maximize the benefit of testing for
effective use of the drug
service and supports required for the
system not just for the
instrument and again as i mentioned
reimbursement
is there economic data to support
reimbursement
okay what about
issues or bottlenecks or speed bumps
what can you do to streamline to
streamline the diagnostic development
we all we know there is risk with drug
development
are we making it any less risky by
adding diagnostic development hopefully
the answer to that question is yes
so the first question here is what if
your previously ubiquitous drug serves
only a subset of the target
population
well this may not be an issue
with the pfizer drugs al corey
only two percent of non-small cell lung
cancer patients
have the l-translocation
however
the response rate for this drug was 57
when patients had translocation positive
lung cancer
and in fact this drug received
accelerated approval
what if the biomarker step doesn't need
expectations
so again here we're looking at positive
predictive value and negative predictive
values
where a positive test
reflects the underlying condition being
tested for that is the marker such as a
mutation indicates that the patient will
respond to a drug
what's the certainty of that
on the other hand a false positive is
the event that the test makes a positive
prediction
and the patient has a negative result
under the gold standard i.e that the
patient has the mutation but does not
respond to the drug
what if your assay contains ru reagents
this may or may not present a problem
depending on the timing and the
complexity
of the reagent
if pharma plans to turn an ruo assay
into an iuo or an ivd assay
then the components of the system must
be examined for any issues related to
this
and hopefully bridging studies are not
required
if the design history file is not
complete well this depends on how
complete or incomplete and on a
case-by-case basis we can work through
an issue such as this
and then finally do i need a bridging
study hopefully not
as discussed we want to avoid bridging
when when if at all possible
okay this is my second to the last slide
how can you work with a diagnostics
partner it's easy to say
have a plan
careful consideration of the development
and commercialization objectives is very
important
structuring the deal and the milestones
to match the risk
not only for the drug development for
the but also for diagnostic development
is important
and then you want to control your
choices so once your prototype
has been selected in feasibility you
want to stick as close as possible to
that without making additional changes
you want to assess all of your essay
components early
and it's very important to have good
communication
with your partner
as well as with the fda
and they encourage
pre-submission meetings early and often
so in in summary regulatory expertise
and commercial infrastructure
infrastructure are very important
our key conclusions are shown here
life technologies partners with pharma
to develop companion diagnostic tests
so when selecting a companion
diagnostics partner
ask what are your development and
commercial goals
life tech has many
ibd platform options
in sequencing and real-time pcr
however like tech provides more than
just technology
we have a number of strategies as i've
described
we encourage avoiding changes that can
add unnecessary expense or delays
we have expertise in product development
as that's been our core business for
many years
we have experienced product development
for ivd
and we have
access to development of ldt pma assays
through cros
and
in addition we can work with our cross
through clinical validation regulatory
and manufacturing
our global commercialization
capabilities are already in place
and as i mentioned we have cro
partnerships
that support custom needs we have a
regulatory group
that provides support to all of our
molecular diagnostics projects
and finally we have a commitment to
targeted therapies
personalized medicine with a strong
presence in medical diagnostics and
genomic medicine
so thank you all for your attention and
attendance today
and i'm available to answer any
questions you might have thank you very
much
you